You may think that having a stroke is
unlikely, but stroke is the leading cause
of disability in American adults. This
doesn't mean that damaged caused by
stroke is unpreventable. The sooner a
stroke victim receives treatment, the
lower their risk of lifelong disability
or death. Because of this, it's important
to be able to recognize the signs of a
stroke, so that you can come to the aid
of yourself or others should a stroke
occur. A stroke happens when blood flow
is unable to reach an area of the brain. Like the rest of the body, brain cells
depend on oxygen, which is supplied by
the bloodstream. Without it, brain cells
begin to die, and the functions
associated with them, such as sensation,
muscle control, and memory are lost. In
the event of a stroke, it's important to
recognize the signs FAST:
Face. have the person's smile does one side of their
face droop downwards.
Arms. have the person raise their arms
does one arm sag down.
Speech. Is the
person's speech slurred, or unusual in
some other way?
Time. In the event of any of these signs,
call 9-1-1 assistance. Stroke can occur in
anybody and at any time. But equipped with
the proper knowledge, you can be a
life savers.
you